it's not it's not easy to pick up the
phone they nobody as a nobody I am and
and talked to a living legend like
Howard Zinn and asked him would you like
to come to a light to give a conference
but there is one one quote that is
seared in my memory from our that give
me courage when I need to pick up the
phone and ask him and that is the
original flag big enough to cover the
shame of taking innocent lives and
whenever I am afraid I talking to him I
remember to myself that quote and pick
up the phone so I said Howard we would
like to organize a conference similar to
what you've done with Gino in Rome in
2005 about just war and he said well if
I have the time I'll be happy thank you
very much for agreeing to be here
tonight and then I received no strategy
no Strada is on his way to
he's on his way to Colorado where next
week he will be receiving a honorary
degree from Colorado College in Colorado
Springs and I said gee no since you are
on your way to Colorado would you like
to come to LA and have a conference with
our and and so this is how we came to
this to this evening and again there is
a long story that I cannot recall to you
but the reason why I try my best to
serve a mercy USA which is trying to
learn from emergency which was founded
by Gino is that Gino is the man who said
that either human rights are for
everybody or are just privileges and
that gives me courage whenever remember
that close to say Gino we got to go
ahead and do something more and then I
would like to thank the most important
ingredient on tonight which is all of
you because I think you're gonna go a
home tonight and remember May 12 2006 as
a special night is the night and you
came out to hear Howard Zinn and gene
Estrada and these two extraordinary
people are gonna touch your mind they're
gonna touch your heart
but it's gonna mean nothing if that
touching of your mind and touch of your
heart is not translate into action it
will be up to you if we're going to have
some extra hands extra minds extra
hearts extra leg upon which emergency
USA is gonna walk thank you very much
I knew I was forgetting something it's
midline for the sound system the sound
system works perfectly is the power that
has some problem so thank you Smith -
well thanks good evening everybody
welcome to the church it's such a
familiar place now and really feels like
coming home and it always feels
wonderful to see KPFK listeners in the
audience just you know it's just really
wonderful to have this kind of response
on such a short notice and we didn't
really have that much time to publicize
the event but perhaps that was good
because I don't know how we could have
managed a bigger crowd than this I'm
gonna give you a brief rundown of what
we're going to be doing today and then
I'll introduce dr. Gino Estrada we are
going to hear first from dr. strata he's
gonna speak for a few minutes and he'll
be telling us about the clinic this
we're here for fundraise I mean I know
we're here to see Howard Zinn and you
know strata but primarily we're hoping
to raise funds this evening for a clinic
in Sudan so we'll be giving you details
about that and you might as well get
your wallets and your checks checkbooks
ready I know it's a little early for the
fun drive but I'll just sort of get
warmed up tonight in asking you to
donate generously to help open this
clinic so just so you know that's coming
and then I'll introduce Howard Zinn he
will be speaking for as you know long as
he likes and who are we to stop Howard
Zinn from okay Howard you have two
minutes left and then we'll have a few
minutes of questions but it'll have to
be brief because you don't want the
event to go on interminably and Howard
has to catch a flight back early in the
morning and then we'll also have a brief
time to do a book signing so that's
basically what we have going for the
evening oh by the way I want to give a
shout out to the Pacifica Radio archives
which is also in the house Brian
DeShazer
is taping a Howard Zinn
and the archives has of course such an
enormous collection of Zins words and
voices a voice and so many other voices
so tonight we'll be added to that
archive dr. gene Estrada is a man of the
world when you look at what he's done
it's it's pretty impressive it's pretty
amazing but it gives you some context
for why he does what he does
currently why he's interested in
humanitarian work he graduated in Milan
and specialized in surgery and during
the 1980s was mainly involved with heart
surgery and heart lung transplants
spending a lot of time in the United
States particularly at Stanford and
Pittsburgh universities he worked at
hair field hospital in the UK and Groot
sure hospital in Cape Town South Africa
in 1998 he decided to apply his surgical
experience to helping and treating
victims of war from 89 to 94 he worked
with the International Red Cross in so
many different war zones from Pakistan
to Ethiopia Thailand Afghanistan Peru
Djibouti Somalia and Bosnia and all of
this experience that he has accumulated
from years of surgery convinced him for
the of the need for a small agile and
highly specialized organization that's
capable of intervening on behalf of
civilians and war victims are not
hampered by government bureaucracy and
the sluggishness of large
non-governmental organizations so it's
very very scanty resources dr. gene
Estrada and a group of friends and
colleagues founded the group emergency
in 1994 twelve years ago and since then
emergency has successfully operated in
open hospitals and rehab centers in
Sierra Leone Cambodia Afghanistan Iraq
very often offering the only support to
victims of land mines and other war
related injuries dr. Jeanne Estrada
spoke alongside professor Howard Zinn in
Rome and has written the introduction to
the book just war that is available for
sale today some of you have those copies
please join me in welcoming dr. Jeanne
Estrada
thanks very much good evening or I could
have talked to you about my personal
experience of about 20 years in
different war zones and and about more
important the experience of emergency
life support for civilian war victims is
the name of the organization many many
years ago I was curious to see how my
job of it being a surgeon would look
like in in so-called poor countries or
third world countries and what I found
was this kind of situation I mean these
are the hospitals that you will find
even today in most of these countries it
would be very difficult to call these
hospitals I mean they should be called
lands or dirty places where patients
receive no attention whatsoever and
where in fact are the families in charge
of looking after their relatives
despite this situation or in addition to
that the level of medical care in these
countries is not only poor and very
often disgusting is not free of charge
people must pay to have this kind of
care and if you cannot afford to pay you
are basically condemned to die so this
question after a while came to my mind
but who is paying the price of war who
are the war victims so it was curious
and I started to collect data from my
Hospital in Kabul in Afghanistan and I
went through the record of over 12,000
patients to discover this reality that I
did not expect that 34 percent of the
victims were children below 14 years of
age 26 percent male adults no
buttons and then women and only 7% in
fact or the victims were taking part to
distill it these were combatants this
was very shocking to me so I tried to
look into the problem and see and find
reasons for that and in fact I have
discovered that a war had evolved over
the previous decades particularly if we
compare the situation that was present
after World War 1 we can see that at the
end of that war only some 15 percent of
the victims were combatant were
civilians the vast majority of the
victims were combatants in other terms
the civilian population were kept sorted
the margin of they're still ities and
this situation that to characterize wars
until in 1915 in fact reversed with
World War two at the end of World War
two the percentage of civilian
casualties was between 60 and 65 percent
which means the ratio reversed hours
days possible for sure several factors
contributed to that the most important
were the Holocaust and genocide attempt
as well as the carpet bombing of major
European cities during World War two and
finally the use of the most devastating
weapons of mass destruction like the
atomic bomb
at the end of that huge tragedy which
caused to the lives of some 5060 million
people there were new hopes new hopes
for a better world
hopes that the world will not have been
the same again and that's when the
United Nations started he's interesting
to read today 60 years later the United
Nations chapter which gives the
rationale for establishing the UN to
save succeeding generations from the
scourge of war which twice in our
lifetime has brought untold sorrow to
mankind and to reaffirm faith in
fundamental human rights in the dignity
and worth of the human person in the
Equal Rights of men and women and of
Nations largest mall these were new
hopes and there were also new tools like
this the UN Security Council that was
established with their primary goal of
ensuring international peace and
security and again there were new
principles a new philosophy that should
have shaved the planet in the coming
decades the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights signed in 1948 was one of
these documents fundamental everyone is
the right to a standard of living
adequate for the health and well-being
of himself and his family including food
clothing housing and medical care well
unfortunately things did not go that way
after World War two instead of seeing
the promotion of human rights the
implementation of human rights we have
witnessed something very different the
world has seen an unprecedented arm
raise arms have been made available to
everybody
here you can see different types of
weapons rockets machine guns cluster
bombs this yellow cylinders with a white
cotton parachute and for sure this arms
race contributed to change further the
situation just to give an idea of the
amount of money that has been spent and
is presently spent in military in 2004
the world military expenditures sum to
1035 billion dollars which is roughly
the amount of money they have available
to survive two billion people in the
planet the poorest one third of the
world population and instead of
promoting human rights and promoting
peace and security the United Nations
Security Council particularly their five
permanent members China France Russia
United Kingdom United States in fact
started to produce and export and sell
not human rights but weapons eighty-five
percent of the weapons circulating the
world are produced by these countries so
this has been the end result that in old
conflicts after 1946 the percentage of
civilian casualties further increase up
to ninety percent of the total which
means war has evolved dramatically if
you compare these two slides you can see
that we still call a use the same term
war to mean two completely different
scenarios in today's conflicts doesn't
matter who is officially the enemy is
the civilian population was going to pay
the price nine victims after ten are
civilians and three victims out of ten
are children
well this basically formed a rationale
for establishing emergency 12 years ago
an organization with this objective to
provide high standard and free-of-charge
medical and surgical care in wharton
zones and in doing that hopefully to
promote a culture of peace and respect
to human rights
we started in 1994 with surgery for what
wounded you can see here some of this
wood it injured by shrapnel from bounce
rockets fry from injured by
high-velocity bullets injured by
anti-personnel mines I'm going to show
you a few slides about anti-personnel
mines they're a bit rough I don't
apologize for that but these are
different types of landmines that do not
look like that in reality normally
landmines are not so visible this is a
dry river that I photographed in Iraq
back in 95 one of these stones is in
fact a landmine you can see there and if
you step on one of these mines you will
end up like this other mines are even
more powerful and will just torn the
victim to pieces as it happens to these
children admit that or hospitals in
Kabul and this again is a rather type of
landmine also called toy mine this is
what the Afghans call green parrots the
size is about the back of a cigarette
and the mind goes off only if you pick
it up from the ground and manipulate it
for a while next slide
this is what happens to your hand or
even more tragic many children will have
one or both hands amputated and we
remain blind because of the explosion
that affects the chest in the face we
started to look after the wounded in our
surgical centers here you see some
examples this is the surgical center in
Kabul intensive care unit and the CT
scan we have there this is one of the
hospitals in Iraq established back in
1998 this is a hospital in Cambodia this
is one of the surgical ward and this is
another emergency hospital in Sierra
Leone and around the hospitals we
established first aid post and Clinics
and of course being involved with the
war injured people means also been
involved in rehabilitation because you
must think about the future of these
victims next so we try to organize
rehabilitation centers where patients
can have physiotherapy can have a
prosthetic fitting and at the end can
start the phase of what we call social
reintegration which means teaching
patients a job trying to have the
patient supporting their own families
and organizing occasional training
workshops so that the patient can again
go back to life with dignity and being
useful for the society at the moment we
have 162 cooperatives in Iraq made by
former patients fully rehabilitated next
from treating the world wound that we
move to treat the victims of war which
is different concept you know children
who die from preventable diseases or
women who cannot have a safe pregnancy
anymore because war has destroyed all
the medical infrastructure although they
were not hit by bullets or landmines
there are victims of war and that's why
we organize pediatric departments like
that one in Afghanistan or these were in
Sierra Leone and maternity hospitals
like this in northern Afghanistan
from 1994 to 2005 we have been treating
more than 1.8 million victims of war
worldwide as you can see from the graph
the peak happened in the last three four
years and this is due to the fact that
besides surgical cases we started to
treat medical cases and also due to the
fact that our largest operations are in
Afghanistan and in Iraq and in Sudan at
the moment
and finally we try to move from
war-related urgent needs to what we have
called a share in human rights because
we are convinced that the right to be
cured if you are sick or wounded is a
basic human right and that's how we
designed the recent projects
particularly the Sudan project a project
that started in there for their food is
today on the media attention more for
political reasons that for humanitarian
reasons everybody is talking about
genocide in Darfur which is not true
there is a big tragedy a big
humanitarian tragedy in a civil war that
is ongoing since 20 years and has been
left for 20 years without any kind of
interest or intervention by the
international community and only
recently I suspect more for political
reasons that for humanitarian reasons
their food has come to the word
attention in therefore we have
completely refurbished the surgical
department in the capital city of
northern therefore alpha share and also
we started in Sudan another project
which is a paediatric program
this is the clinic we have opened in the
internally displaced people camp of Mayo
and the clinic is presently looking
after the children that are living in
slams around Khartoum more than 2
million refugees live around Khartoum in
terrible conditions without water
without electricity without medical care
but we wanted to do something more and
that's why we have added to the Sudan
project this third component which is
cardiac surgery why cardiac surgery in
Sudan why this kind of highly
specialized medicine in a country where
people are still dying because of
diarrhea or preventable diseases well
the answer is quite simple if we look at
the problem in terms of human rights we
must admit that human rights belong to
each and every human being not only to
to reach people so if we think that we
have the right to be cured when we have
a cardiac problem the same right applies
to the people live in Sudan or in
neighboring countries that's how we
decided to go ahead with this program
the regional center for cardiac surgery
that we call Salaam meaning peace in
Arabic is presently under construction
in Khartoum and it will be finished by
the end of this year so within this year
we will start surgical activities the
center will serve not only Sudan but
also the neighboring countries here you
see some phases of the construction on
the center yeah
next
and we hope that this Center will help
to pass a different message into that
area and the messages that we consider
those people equal to us in rights and
dignity as stated in the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights
what what did we learn in this 12 years
experience in war zones first that in
contemporary conflicts 90% of the
victims are civilians one-third children
the second that the humanitarian action
must be based on this principle the
article 1 of the Universal Declaration
in other terms we cannot accept a
humanitarian action that sees medical
care as something very technological
sophisticated effective if you are
talking about our countries but then
when we think about the poor countries
of the world we tend to believe that
sending out a few drugs a few tablets
and some syringes is more than enough is
not enough what we have learnt in these
years is that we must set up hospitals
where we would be happy to be treated
ourselves to have our family members and
our friends treated there if these
hospitals are good for them
if the hospitals are good for us means
they are also good for those people and
then we have learned that unfortunately
for most or the world governments war is
always seen as the solution of a problem
but for the war citizens war is not the
solution war is exactly the problem is
because of word that the word citizens
remain killed or maimed or wounded and
they are poor or angry or they are
forced to leave their homes and leave as
refugees and finally we have learned
that recognizing the basic equality in
rights and dignity of all human beings
is exactly the foundation of freedom
justice and peace in the world as stated
in the Universal Declaration of Human
Rights for this we have come to this
conclusion that today there is no more
justification for war there's no more
historical justification there's no more
political justification and there's no
more ethical justification so we've
fully realized and fully appreciate the
thoughts of Albert Einstein when back in
1932 he stated that war cannot be
humanized that war can only be abolished
and this is exactly the goal that is in
front of us and I'm convinced that if
human beings will not be able to push
war out of the history war will push
human beings out of the history thank
you very much
thank you dr. gene Estrada for that
really really important foundation that
I think all of us need to be reminded of
so often we come now to the time in our
program when we ask you to translate
your compassion your enthusiasm your
appreciation for what you've heard
tonight and what you're about to hear
into dollars because all of those
infrastructures all of those structures
that you saw in the slides don't come
cheap
remember a hospital that would be good
enough to get yourself treated in as you
know somebody from Sierra Leone or
Afghanistan or Iraq that takes money so
I know that you've paid a little money
to get in here we're now going to ask
you to dig a little bit deeper as deep
as you can and there are volunteers
standing by with little cardboard boxes
that they're gonna start passing out now
you can empty your pockets but even
better pull out your checkbooks and make
checks to emergency USA that's emergency
USA they are tax deductible I understand
make as big a check as you can donate as
generously as you can my own work
outside of KPFK is helping to raise
funds for humanitarian programs i
underst I know how hard it is to raise
funds for these issues I know also how
hard it is to sustain the interest and
while we have your interest we really
want you to do whatever you can you know
it's it's it's sometimes people think
well what's the point if you know I want
to I want to work for political change
it's easy to give money but it's hard to
do politically change so I want to be an
activist well guess what it's actually
not easy to give money right if it was
easy you would give more of it and and
and so really and I think I think that's
the difficult step we know that you're
all activists and so we want you to also
be a generous humanitarian tonight and
donate as much as you can again
emergency USA is the name that you can
make the checks out to or give cash or
give whatever you can and they are the
donations are tax-deductible give as
generously as you can because truly
you know these are issues that affect
every single one of us we live here in
such privilege and you know a relative
privilege I should say and and when we
see the images of what's happening in
the in the parts of the world around our
country it's sometimes hard to fathom
that those are real human beings with
real feelings and limbs that are missing
in lives that are being destroyed so so
we can do you know the littlest bit and
spare as much as we possibly can so
please do donate as generously as you
can now comes my favorite part of the
program to introduce a person who I have
been deeply inspired by I'm an immigrant
to the United States and when I first
began educating myself politically
Howard Zinn's people's history of the
United States was an absolutely crucial
part of my education
and I have to say that that book enables
me to look a right-wing white male in
the eye who tells me that as Ana as an
immigrant
I'm not fulfilling you know the American
Way or I'm not living the the good
patriotic life of an American by
speaking out and criticizing this
government and all I have to do a site
Howard Zinn's history and say no I am
following exactly in the footsteps of
the rich legacy of descent in this
country that is part of the history of
this country and I am so proud because
that is the America that I love the
America of the workers and the laborers
and longshoremen and the garment workers
those are the Americans whose footsteps
I do feel that I am hopefully following
in and whose legacy I hope to continue
and that you know I wouldn't have had
that confidence had it not been for this
very powerful and very important book I
want to quote briefly from a essay
written by Howard Zinn in 2001 December
2001 which crystallizes for me what an
important voice he is Afghanistan is an
issue close to my heart some of you may
know I I do solidarity work with a
women's group in Afghanistan and in
December 2001 it was only two months two
and a half months after the u.s. had
begun bombing Afghanistan and Howard
Zinn wrote an essay called a Just Cause
not a just war but he said I believe to
moral arguments can be made about the
president present a so called war the
September 11th attack constitutes a
crime against humanity and cannot be
justified and the bombing of Afghanistan
is also a crime which cannot be
justified and yet voices across the
political spectrum many on the Left have
described this war as a quote just war
I've puzzled over this
how can a war be truly just when it
involves the daily killing of civilians
when it causes hundreds of thousands of
men and women and children to leave
their homes to escape the bombs when it
may not find those who planned the
September 11th attacks and when it will
multiply the ranks of people who are
angry enough for this country to become
terrorists
selves this war a monster gross
violation of Human Rights and it will
produce the exact opposite of what is
wanted it will not end terrorism it will
proliferate terrorism okay that was that
was December 2001 we are now in May 2006
and the words that Howard Zinn said back
then have come true we have seen a
strengthening of fundamentalist forces
in the form of the Northern Alliance the
Taliban al-qaeda you name it and
Afghanistan once more being forgotten
has in fact become another haven for
terrorists just as it was before 9/11
meanwhile of course the ordinary people
are caught between the forces of M
Western imperialism and Islamic
fundamentalism so I thank Howard Zinn
for speaking out at a time when it was
really difficult to question the Justice
of this war the so called just war
Howard Zinn is a historian playwright
social activist he was a shipyard worker
and Air Force Bombardier before he went
to college under the GI Bill and
received his PhD from Columbia
University he started Spelman College in
Boston University and been a visiting
professor at the University of Paris and
the University of Bologna he's received
many awards including the Thomas Merton
award the Eugene Debs award the Upton
Sinclair award and the Lannon literary
award and he's written of course many
many books including people's history of
the United States and his latest book
Just War which he will be signing copies
off tonight after his presentation
please join me in welcoming professor
Howard Sims
and by the way make checks are two
emergency USA while you're listening to
our
Thank You Sonali Thank You KPFK thank
you emergency emergency has this
remarkable bunch of people here in LA
who came out of nowhere just like LA
came out of nowhere I guess and they're
obviously very good organizers well I've
known Gino Strada for a few years now I
I got to know him when I was asked to
write an introduction to his book green
parrots a War surgeons diary which I
urge you all to read and so I did it and
writing the introduction of course I had
to read it sometimes that happens and so
difficult book to read well obviously
and you know and and Gino has shown you
here that kind of work he's done and you
can only imagine what in 10 to 15 years
of who of working on war victims what
that means
what's that's like but what interested
me was when I came to the end of his
book and the end of his book he says it
in effect I don't want to do this
anymore
I don't want to operate on children
anymore I don't want to amputate the
arms of kids who've been devastated by
land mines anymore you know we need to
abolish war and and then he invited me
to Rome which is first a difficult
invitation to accept
but I went and and and then you might
say he enlisted me and the idea of
starting to spread the word in this
country and and everywhere the word that
we cannot accept war anymore as a
solution for any of the problems that we
have in the world I mean we are now
struggling we in this country to stop
the war in Iraq where we're working very
hard on that and and we're going to
succeed the war in Iraq is going to have
to come to an end
and but what happens then what happens
after the war in Iraq our country has
been fighting war after war after war
ever since the end of World War two ever
since that war which was supposed to
bring an end to war and after Vietnam we
thought no no more wars and then the
government decided also oh well the
people of the United States that
apparently have turned against war this
is bad
they described what they call the
Vietnam syndrome syndrome is is a word
for sickness the sickness was that the
American people had turned against the
government against the FBI against
Congress against the establishment
against the war this was the Vietnam
syndrome and the United States
government set out to somehow do away
with that syndrome by fighting small
quick victorious wars against weak
opponents to get the American population
accustomed to war you know once again
and this is what they've been trying to
do and the Iraq war represents the
latest of it except that it hasn't been
quick it's been going on for three years
and
and it may be that the Vietnam syndrome
has not been eliminated
that the American people are beginning
to understand the futility of war the
immorality of war was seeing a growth in
consciousness among the American people
and and that's a very positive
encouraging thing to see but what comes
next
you know they're already beating a drum
school for war in Iran right already
talking about bombing Iran already
drawing up the plans and when they're
confronted with this they said we're
only drawing up plans
they're creating a hysteria about Iran
the way they created hysteria about Iraq
I don't think they will succeed this
time I think the American people have
learned something about the war in Iraq
which makes them more suspicious of what
the government is saying about Iran but
I think we have to think about not this
war not the next war we don't want to
have to create another anti-war movement
and another anti-war movement and
another anti-war movement we really have
to present in the world the idea and
idea which which is so obviously utopian
and long-term but an idea which
absolutely must take hold it's time has
come you know and the idea that war must
be abolished and geno strata showed you
you know told you about I about
Einstein's quote when Einstein said that
1932 he was attending a conference in
Geneva which was called a disarmament
conference anytime you see the words
disarmament conference be suspicious
when the governments of the world used
the word disarmament they they don't
mean it and so Einstein attend to this
disarmament conference he he like so
many people is disillusioned by a horror
of World War 1 and what did he hear at
this disarmament conference he heard
these nations talking about well these
weapons will be banned and these weapons
will be okay and he did something which
nobody expected I decided to do he
called a press conference
Einstein doesn't do things like that but
he did and he said
and you saw those words on the screen
war cannot be humanized war can only be
abolished and that's that's a theme of
this campaign that we want to initiate
and you're part of the initiation we
expect you to spread the word you expect
you know not just to stop the war in
Iraq but we expect you to begin talking
to everybody who can about the abolition
of war itself governments are not going
to do it
governments can never be dependent to
advance the cause of peace or justice a
human rights I mean in in the course of
human history governments have never
been dependable in taking care of the
needs of people and after all
governments are not set up for that
purpose governments are set up to serve
certain interests and those not I'm not
the interests of the people this is a
very important thing for people to grasp
people have some naive conception that
we very often grow up with in this
country that the government is our
friend and the you know know the
government is not our friend
occasionally
occasionally it can get friendly when
there's a great People's Movement that
compels it to be friendly and then you
know so it is really up to us it is up
to the people of the world to abolish
war because governments won't do it very
often here
it's said that well people are not gonna
do it because war is part of human
nature how many times have you heard
that how many times have you heard they
not I think I once figured it out
anytime you get into a discussion of war
like 12 minutes into the conversation
somebody says oh it's human nature test
that out it's a it's a scientific
observation of mine in 12 minutes yeah
if war were a part of human nature
governments would not have to go to such
enormous lengths to persuade people to
go to war people would rush
spontaneously know.they governments have
to work at it that worked very hard at
the natural instincts of people are not
for war the natural instincts of people
are for compassion and comradeship and
brotherhood and sisterhood does the
natural instincts of people but
governments work work very hard they
work by seduction they work by
propaganda and they work by coercion to
get people to go to war know it at the
end of World War two when the Nazi
leaders were being tried in Nuremberg
and they were in their prison cells
awaiting trial and a psychologist was
given the job of interviewing these Nazi
leaders in their prison cells talking to
them and one of them wrote a book he
kept a diary he kept notes and he
records in his book a conversation he
had with him and Goering
second-in-command to Hitler head of the
Luftwaffe and
and he asked well how come the German
people went along with Hitler and
Goering said well of course people don't
want war they you some poor slob this
was going his words I don't know what
the word is in German but this is how
the interpreter it translated some poor
slob working on a farm he doesn't want
to go to war but he can be convinced he
can be propagandized he can be told
there's a an enemy out there that must
be defeated he can be told that this is
done for the country this is done for
the people and and then you can mobilize
a population for war and this is true
Goering said in any country that last
part of it was interesting to me it's
not just totalitarian governments it's
not just tyrannical governments that
propagandize their people for war it's
so-called democratic liberal governments
and of course that has happened in this
country again and again and again where
people have been deceived people have
been lied to
we're now aware all the lies and
deceptions that have been told in
connection with the this war in Iraq but
the the history of government lies and
deception in order to get the people of
the country to go to war that goes way
back I mean how else can governments get
people who go to war and goes back to
the Mexican War it goes back to the war
in Cuba and it goes back to the
Philippines it goes back through all the
wars that we've fought the deception
lives and that's how they do it
our job is to reach back to the
essential feelings of people and to
break through these fogs of propaganda
and cries for war these false slogans
that are raised that talk about we're
going to walk the democracy we're going
to war for freedom we now have a history
which shows that all these so-called
wars for freedom and democracy have not
brought freedom and democracy to any of
the people that we've waged war against
and and they certainly haven't brought
freedom democracy to this country
and
you will hear them say Memorial Day is
coming up come to think of it Memorial
Day is coming up in the other smother
and you could have a lot of flag waving
and a lot of trumpets blowing and a lot
of speeches made honoring the the dead
of wars and of course yes the people who
died in wars should be honored but war
should not be honored and the makers of
war should not be harder you say and you
will you will hear the speech makers say
they gave their lives for their country
how many times have you heard that they
gave their lives for their country
there's a double lie in that one they
did not give their lives their lives
were taken away from them you say and
second they didn't die for their country
they died for their government they they
they did the country the country did not
profit from their deaths there were
people there were interests that profit
from the deaths in the present case that
the young people who were dying in Iraq
thank you the young people who are dying
in Iraq that's Marco takes
he's keeping me alive the regular doses
of water and who knows what else to say
but the young people who are dying in
Iraq are not dying for the country there
it's a terrible thing to say the country
is not benefiting from their debts
they're dying for for Bush and Cheney
they dying for Halliburton and the
corporations that make money out of war
wise men throughout history have
recognized this plutocrat this the the
poor go to war for the benefit of the
rich Eugene Debs recognized this he was
sent to prison for ten years in World
War one for saying it's the poor the
working class who fight the wars and and
it's the rich who send them to war
I went through a certain trajectory
myself about war because it was a time
when I believed in the concept of just
war as I believe that to adjust wars and
unjust Wars good wars and bad was and I
think that's very very common belief in
in among people you know
oh I once had a student who wrote a
paper about war and in her paper she
said no wars
I like whines there were good years and
bad years the good wars and bad lawyers
but she said war is not like wine wars
like cyanide one drop in you're dead I
always remembered what she said because
it's fitted fitted my own my own
experience might the development of my
own thought because I I I've volunteered
for the Second World War had to tell you
what war it was so that you wouldn't
think it was the spanish-american war
but I heared for for that war and became
a bombardier in the Air Force and
because I yeah I believe this was yes it
was right it was a good war Studs Terkel
has done a world history of people who
who lived through World War two and he
calls it the good war although if you
look closely you'll see he put quotation
marks around good war because as he
talked to people more and more he found
more and more questions from people who
would participate in the war about the
war what happened to me is I I entered
the wars an enthusiastic Bombardier and
what could be more just to his war
against fascism work to be more evil in
the world
they're trying to portray all these
these two-bit dictators in the world as
Hitler's no you know Noriega of Panama
Sodom was saying no now Hitler was evil
incarnate
yes and that fascism was evil and so yes
I believed in this war and so I went
ahead and I dropped bombs on various
cities and in Europe on in Germany and
Czechoslovakia Hungary and even France
and
it wasn't until the war ended that I
began to think about what I had been
doing I read John Hersey's account of
his interviews with the survivors of
Hiroshima remember he was the journalist
who wanted to Hiroshima after the
bombing and talked to the survivors if
they imagine what the survivors looked
like people without Armas people without
legs
blind people whose skin you couldn't
bear to look at and he recorded what
what they told him and I read that and I
realized that I did not know when I
dropped my bombs what I was doing to
human beings do you drop bombs from
30,000 feet high six miles high you
don't see any people you don't you don't
hear screams you don't see blood you
don't know what you're doing is this is
so much the nature of modern warfare
you know people blithely send off
rockets and cruise missiles and drop
bombs and they really don't know what
they are doing and they come back and
you see them on television exultant we
oh we just completed our mission I
remember those pictures at the end of
the during the first Gulf War the pilots
would come back for their missions we
hit our targets the truth is they did
not know what they hit and so I began to
think about that and and and we have to
think about Hiroshima and Nagasaki and
think about those several hundred
thousand people who who died these these
were not the people who bombed Pearl
Harbor these were the children of
Hiroshima and Nagasaki I mean I think
about the hundred thousand people in
Tokyo who died in one night of fire
bombing in Tokyo in the spring of 1945
one night of fire body and we had
denounced the fascists for bombing
civilian populations we had denounced
them for their cruelty their brutality
and here we were and look the bombing of
Dresden and bombing it you know 30,000
40,000 60,000 people Frankfurt Hamburg
altogether perhaps six hundred thousand
civilians in in Germany died in the
bombing trial an equal number died
600,000 or so in Japan you have to think
about the good war and the just war and
realize that war poisons everybody who
engages in it
well and you start off I mean I
recreated this my own psychology that is
starting off deciding these are the bad
guys we are the good guys and then
realizing that once I had made that
initial decision that they are the bad
guys and we're the good guys once I made
that initial decision I didn't have to
think anymore I didn't have to question
anything anymore
from that point on anything goes that's
just the psychology of other just war
you know and and so then then Hiroshima
and Nagasaki and then Tokyo then
anything can happen and I didn't realize
was that what war does is it turns
everybody into bad guys both sides
whatever the the initiating situation
was and and you can look back to through
history and you see this happening again
you go back to the telephone even though
the Athenians were the good guys and the
Spartans were the bad guys and and and
then in the course of the war the
Athenians begin to behave just like the
Spartans so yeah I began to think about
here I was I was testing war by its best
exam
for World War two this example that
everybody points to and they say well
you know there is such a thing as a good
war in World War two as an example so I
was I wanted to take that the most
extreme test of the idea of a good war
which is world war two and when I looked
at it I came away with a much more
complex view of this good war than I had
at the beginning and I realized that
what happens
in war even a war against a tyrant and
war is always against a tyrant there's
always a tyrant to make war when you
make war against a tyrant the people you
kill are the victims of the tyrant this
is what we've been doing all along
people we've been killing in the Iraq
and saying oh we you know Saddam Hussein
we've got to get rid of Sodom said
people who clearly right are the victims
of Saddam Hussein
so yeah and now I looked at the world
after the war as the years went went by
and I had I at the end of the war I'd
gotten a letter from general Marshall
who's the general of generals in World
War two and I think was the first
five-star general it was you might say a
personal letter addressed to me and 16
million others who had served in the
military and the letter says something
like congratulations we've won the war
against the terrible foe and it will be
a new world well looking around I'm and
you saw in Jesus chart about the wars
that have followed World War two looking
around the world after the war we had
defeated fascism with Mussolini Hitler
the attack the Japanese military machine
we had not defeated fascism around the
world there was still fascism in the
world is still racism in the world
they're still militarism in the world
and they're still war war after war
after war
so I I came to conclusion of war as a
quick fix as violence as always a quick
fix we can't really solve a problem
intelligently it turned to violence you
know and violence seems to solve
something well it's like a drug and war
is a drug you know you win and you you
have a high don't ask me how I know this
but you win the war this moment of
exultation I remember when the war ended
in Europe and I was there in England and
the lights went on all over England and
we poured into the streets for the first
time with with the lights on in the city
of Norwich England then they were
passing out fish and chips to everybody
free as all that exultation and then the
reality sets in and the reality after
World War Two was fifty million people
had died and we were still going through
war after war and so yes we we have to
decide once and for all no matter how
long it takes and after the movement
against slavery was a utopian movement
in the 1830s I mean how are you gonna
Bala SHhhh slavery
they're holding four million black
people and slavery and it's very useful
to them we're not going to be able to do
this but a movement grew slavery was not
abolished just by the Emancipation
Proclamation a movement an anti-slavery
movement grew it seemed utopian at the
beginning but it grew and grew and grew
and finally reached a point with Lincoln
and Congress had to react to and slavery
was abolished as possible it's possible
to end war it's you can go through
experience and bad experience bad
experience of that experience and you
begin to think we we can't stop this we
can only have bad experiences and then a
certain point is reached where something
snaps and say I have nothing to do this
anymore we have to do that with war
and it's up
and we have to think about this they
cannot carry out Wars without us this
very important thing it's just like the
workers in General Motors in the 1930s
when they faced the enormous Lee
powerful corporation General Motors and
they were working are the conditions
which they didn't like for wages which
were too low and ours which were too
long that we're not going to be able to
defeat General Motors you see and then
they realized General Motors needs us
all we have to do is stop working and
General Motors is helpless that's true
of governments when people decide that
they are not going to support the
government when gi's decide that they
are not going to continue fighting when
they come back from the war and they
organize against the war when the
government simply cannot find enough
people to carry on the war then war must
come to an end this is what happened in
the Vietnam War what happened the
Vietnam War is inhuman many of you
remember this you know that more and
more and more people in the United
States turned away from the government
and the government did not have
legitimacy anymore and it could not
carry on the war when ROTC chapters
closed and when hundreds of thousands of
young people refused to go to war when
the GIS came back and the GIS in the
field were refusing to go out on patrol
and b-52 pilots were refusing to fly
b-52s over Hanoi and Haiphong anymore
and then edits and the Vietnam veterans
came back and they formed Vietnam
Veterans Against the War they threw
their medals over a fence in Washington
DC and at a certain point the government
decided no it it will not be able to
carry on the war
this is beginning to happen in the war
in Iraq and so the war at some point
will come to an end and it is up to us
to decide that we are not going to
support any war whatever reason is given
to us by whatever Liars sit in the White
House we're not going to do that
because before if nothing else aside
from the horrors of war for a very
important reason war and the expenditure
of all of our energy and talent and
national wealth for war is preventing us
from solving the problems that we have
the world a really serious problems that
we have in the world
the sickness and homelessness and the
lack of water in the world and what's
happening to the environment and how do
we deal with natural disasters like
Katrina and what happened in in a show
when the earthquakes come these are
things that are affecting huge huge
numbers of people billions of people and
we're not able to deal with that because
the government's are fixed on war so
that's one very very important reason
for abolishing war because it is
possible to imagine a world without Wars
possible imagine world in which this
very talented human race we are very
talents you know how talented amazing
things are done by human beings we turn
our talents to creating a world where
everybody has health care and everybody
is housed and and and the wearer is
cleaned up and the waters are cleaned up
it's possible to do that
see and
this movie will start modestly here in
this church thank you
thank you so much we are nearly at the
end of our evening we are going to spend
a few minutes on question and answers
and then there will be a book signing I
believe books will be sold over there
and signed over here surprisingly we
have a large stack of questions before
the speech was even over how do you know
what he was what to ask him if he hadn't
even finished yet anyway here's that
here's a big stack of questions we're
not going to get through all of them so
what I'm going to do is I'm gonna have
professors and pick them like as if you
were picking cards from a deck that
we're just gonna have to like do it that
way because we're not gonna get through
how do you motivate a community in this
egotistical society to care about one
another when the community is at war
with itself I am the future my community
is the future and our voice is oppressed
I'm assuming this is coming from a young
person
it's interesting people who ask
questions always think that the people
up here have the answers
and generally people really answer their
own questions the person we ask this
question is obviously motivated and most
people are and one of us we want to do
the thing so all you have those give
them an opportunity creating a space for
them encourage them start out you know
do it first yourself but I believe that
it's not hard to motivate people to to
do the right thing if things happen by
example and the person who asked this
question is an example and so it will
spread I'm sure now trust me you don't
want me to pick I don't want to be
accused of selectively picking these all
right we often hear that democracies
don't war with each other which seems to
be mostly true what do you think about
that
should we take comfort in that that the
only war on other people that that
they've managed to because so-called
democracies are countries which are
advanced industrial countries it's
mostly get mostly get along with one
another and so they vent their wrath and
their anger on most of the world and so
the fact that they may not be at war
with one another should not encourage us
I you know I recall that that Henry
Kissinger if you pardon me for
mentioning his name I recall it Henry
Kissinger he wrote in his doctoral
dissertation you know that you know the
of the period between the the Congress
of Vienna in 1815 and and World War one
was a hundred years of peace well yes it
was peace among the nations of Europe it
was not peace between the nations of
Europe and the peoples of Africa and
Asia it was a period of imperialism of
brutal colonialism and so you know no
let's let's think beyond the so-called
democracies to the need for peace with
all parts of the world yeah okay I'm
actually going to read out a question
directed at dr. gene Estrada which is in
your view is emergency and anti-war
force well I will say that our and to
war
feelings did not originate from you know
a political or ideological choice they
basically originated on the operating
tables how can you be a doctor how can
you look after war wounded in the same
time being favor of this carnage to
continue
so I think it was a human reaction to to
what we have seen and and that's that's
probably the basic point on top of it I
must say that we all felt very disgusted
by the fact that regardless the reason
for fighting award the end result that
we have seen was always the same we have
seen normal people pool people and enopp
killed wounded maimed most of them they
did not even know what was going on
around them I mean can you imagine an
Afghan citizen they don't know why there
is so much violence around them
why foreign militaries are occupying
their countries all the time the
Russians before now the Americas and the
British and the Canadians and the
Italians I mean it would be it would be
very strange to accept this also for us
now we tend to believe that you know
there are countries where people like to
be colonized it's not true
basically what what emergency is is
trying to do is building human rights in
the medical field because we believe
that the only prevention or the only
preventive medicine towards war is the
construction of human rights and that's
what we are trying to do with those
emergency have a website because
emergency have a website that you can
share yeah we have a website which is
WWE you si dot orgy or also a website
Italian website because emergency was
originally established in Italy which is
www.a mergency dot IT
I hope I'm thinking one I can mean yeah
you want to read it okay is mmm
first time in history no-bid
corporations if corporations continue to
create the need for war and resources
how do we stop this and how do we get
these people out first time in history
no no big corporations
I'll answer it the way was asked
but you when you don't really want to
answer a question you just answer in
other questions that you made up
yourself but I will answer this so well
here's something I've been meaning to
say and so this gives me a chance a
question period because it gives you a
chance of say things that you forgot to
say war is a business right corporations
make a lot of money from war there were
all these huge multi-billion contracts
very often no-bid contracts given out to
friends of the politicos I remember
during the Vietnam War there was an
artist in the anti-war movement who did
a poster very simple simple poster with
with these words powerful words but also
chilling war is good for business invest
your son okay
here's another question for dr. gene
Estrada why did emergency open its
medical services in northern Sudan
rather than the south well you know
there's no answer in the sense that if
you look at the world map
I think there's need to open medical
facilities basically in every country or
the planet
if by medical facilities we mean
something where medicine is given free
of charge to human beings as it should
be so in this respect I think the
northern Sudan or South Sudan I am
convinced for instance that the policy
of having health care as a business is a
crime against the society
I said that there is no particular
reason you know many times you open up
operations because you you go to a place
and you happen to have contacts with
certain people before you have contact
with other people and basically
everywhere you turn you see huge needs
and unfortunately we are able to respond
knowledge as much so instead of spending
you know ears and maybe organizing
seminars and congresses to decide is it
better to operate here or there
you better fold your sleeves and start
doing something
last question I've been told sorry
tell are those folks okay this is a
question for professors and you offer
hope that a new war on Iran can be
prevented but Bush can launch a war
without popular support
he now threatens use of nuclear weapons
this will have catastrophic results
what do you think can be done to prevent
this
stalling for time we I think aside from
the fact that I think people people have
learned something from from the war in
Iraq and I think already there's a lot
of skepticism about the drumming up of
the war spirit for Iran we have a we in
the in the movement against the war we
we have an obligation to do a lot of
education about the situation in Iran
you know one sort of simple fact you
know get against the this hysteria fact
which is always buried about that sort
of twelve paragraphs down and and twenty
pages in to the major newspapers is that
all of the nuclear experts all the
experts on nuclear technology tell us
that Iran is five to ten years away from
developing a new one nuclear weapon five
to ten years and and people have to be
confronted with this very simple
juxtaposition that you run is five to
ten years away from possibly developing
one nuclear weapon the United States has
10,000 nuclear weapons
Israel has several hundred nuclear
weapons the idea that this possibility
of a future weapon in Iran is an
imminent threat and therefore deserves
the violent reaction is absurd and
dangerous and stupid